dans les titres même s'ils ont levé leur
barrage ils ne baissent pourtant pas la
garde les agriculteurs maintiennent la
pression sur le gouvernement ce vendredi
de nouvelles actions se se déroulaient
dans nos territoires ablois 9 jours
après leur première visite place de la
République les tracteurs étaient de
retour ce vendredi pour une fois encore
demander audience au préfet Lucas Chopin
et F
junau les mots c'est bien les actes
c'est mieux c'est le message délivré
aujourd'hui par la FNSEA et les jeunes
agriculteurs devant la préfecture de
Loir etcher 50 tracteurs une centaine de
manifestants réunis pour une action
symbolique car si les instan nationales
des syndicats ont annoncé la fin des
mobilisations le gouvernement est
prévenu si mensonges il y a eu les
agriculteurs se montreront encore plus
virulent il faut comprendre queon a eu
des mesures qui ont été annoncées euh en
National maintenant il y a du travail à
faire bah aussi bien au niveau des
ministères que au niveau du département
donc c'est ce qui va commencer à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui mais si les résultats sont
pas satisf faisant ou si c'était juste
des paroles en attendant qu'on r en aus
ferme et qu'on se calme en fait on est
toujours sur le front et prêt à à
revenir et à réintervenir si besoin
plusieurs personnalités politiques sont
venus apporter leur soutien au mouvement
un mouvement bon enfant mais les
annonces du Premier ministre hier n'ont
pas fait réagir que les agriculteurs à
l'exemple des organismes écologistes au
sujet de la suspension du plan écofyo un
plan qui prévoit l'arrêt progressif de
l'utilisation de produits
phytosanitaires c'est une illustration
de plus de la du gouvernement par
rapport à l'écologie j'ai l'impression
qu'on a une agriculture qui est figée
qui veut pas bouger qui ne sait pas
bouger et qui veut pas évoluer alors que
la nature elle et les dégradations
s'amplifi de manière énorme pour les
syndical l'heure est désormais au
travail et aux négociations d'autres
organisations ont quant à elles d'ors et
déjà décidé de revenir à Blois
demain